hello there and podcast land listeners
you're listening to life is short well
we talked about them so many times that
we finally wore them down and got bud
light seltzer to become an official
sponsor but light south so you know how
much we love them we can't wait to tell
you more about them but for now here's
the show
[Music]
when i was a kid like all other kids i
had no hair on my butt
and then over the years you know you get
a little hair down there
about 10 years ago this is maybe 20
years after i began developing hair on
my butt i was gonna do this movie called
going the distance and there was to be a
scene in the movie that heavily featured
my butt
it was suggested that i get my butt
waxed and so i did i went into um a
place i'm trying to remember where i
blocked a lot of it out but i just
remember being
on my back and they have you put your
legs like way up over your head like a
baby like a baby getting what was that
letter we read talked like a
like a baby getting powdered
and um and this woman did it she did it
very with a lot of authority and there
was no i was very embarrassed obviously
because you have you're naked with your
legs spread i mean it's a very
vulnerable position to be in and so i
started talking a lot because i was like
trying to like make it normal you know i
was trying to normalize it and and so
they ripped the hair out and um
and that was just weird doing the scene
because there's so many so much focus on
my butt and there were people lighting
it and makeup women like putting makeup
on and it's an awful visual i wonder if
anyone's still listening
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
you're listening maybe to life is short
i'm your host justin long
sweetheart
[Music]
and with me as always is my uh very
hairy
co-host has the quarantine been
difficult for you because you can't now
get your ass waxed i i haven't done it
since
since quarantine started no you must be
in bad shape down there it's like
no i haven't it's a forest uh no i
haven't done it and and i sort of regret
having done it because
now when i remember seeing the movie for
the first time and because you don't
really ever really get that great a look
at your butt i mean you know you can
look at it in a mirror but how often do
you do that
so when i saw it it was strange to see
my ass from that angle
and and i think i'd show my ass in other
movies but like not to this extent was
it that hairy that no that's what i'm
saying it was like it really was it was
just really the
i don't want to get too graphic but it
was just a part of it too late
have you ever seen a return you know in
return of the jedi the star-like pit
yeah it all kind of like it gets like
harley you get to the whole
shirt
but what kind of movie do you think did
you think you were doing well that's a
crazy thing like i forget who suggested
i think it may have been yeah i gotta
guess yeah shakeman
oh maybe it was shankman adam our
producer it was a movie i did with drew
barrymore and uh two very funny co-stars
jason sedakis
and today's guest
charlie day the hilarious harry yeah you
know i don't know how harry is he might
i bet he's perry
he's got it he's got a scruffy face
that's pretty good thanks um charlie
though i've known for years i knew
charlie uh back in there we'll talk
about it we'll get into it but uh he's
just one of my favorite people he's so
obviously funny but just a really good
guy but just for clarification that
story
uh by your hairy [ __ ]
you told not because uh it reminded you
of charlie
but because
charlie day reminds you of going the
distance oh better set up yeah oh sorry
yeah oh like speaking of harry [ __ ]
our guest today is known yeah that's
true uh it's always harry i just thought
about it that needed a quick
clarification no charlie of course in
addition to well no one really saw going
the distance but you have seen him in
many other things uh
it's always said in philadelphia of
course which he's been doing for many
years the juggernaut it is another
juggernaut um pacific rim speaking of
harry [ __ ] this
pacific rim job
and he's just he's the pet horrible
bosses oh yeah of course parts one and
two people know him from in fact we were
thinking like when we were thinking
about a story to tell uh we were
thinking have we ever had like a really
horrible boss and i fortunately neither
of us well we've had like douchey bosses
and
but nothing yeah it's not horrible never
had a horrible boss
thankfully i've had good bosses yeah me
too i've been pretty lucky um
certainly in movies i've been lucky
enough to work with good uh yeah there
have been a few because you haven't had
a lot of actual boss i yeah it's hard to
say that well i did when i was directors
i guess they're kind of bosses kind of
but not like a boss in a regular job i
mean we talked about this a lot but we
just directed that movie i didn't feel
that much like a boss i didn't feel like
i mean maybe that we should have felt
more like bosses but i have a hard time
even i didn't when we were doing going
the distance i had an assistant named
zanna uh who was such a i who i loved
and still love um and zanna i had a
really hard time
like quote-unquote bossing her around
you know i couldn't like i had a hard
time delegating authority toward it well
i think that's near to doing i think i
would say a good boss never bosses
people around because that's
yeah that felt it didn't sound right um
how did i say this i had a hard time
being a boss yeah i guess so
hmm yeah i i felt guilty yeah you're too
guilty to have employees yeah
but um
like with the landscaping people we have
like yard people here and i always want
to do things yeah you scurried out the
other day to move a chair on the lawn
yeah because i didn't want them to mow
around it yeah but they don't do that
they i mean now i'm gonna sound callous
but uh landscaping people know how to
move a chair two feet mo and move it
back as a fellow mower i know how
annoying annoying is when you've got the
mower going you got to stop it and then
move a thing out of the way it's just
an extra annoying step
right and i felt bad well i'm it's nice
of you but it's an annoying step that
they're very used to i guess so i don't
like it uh okay so let's just get into
it yeah let's get into it okay so here
it is the very funny
very talented
i i would say creative wizard wow yeah
sure
charlie day
life could be a dream sweetheart
that was some fun opening banter i can't
wait to hear this interview what beats
brotherly banter i'll tell you what bud
light seltzer you knew i was gonna say
that set you up yeah well as brothers do
bud like seltzer you're gonna hear a lot
about them you've already heard us
mention them many times but whatever
gets you to try it we would encourage
you to do that whether it just sounds
delicious based on what we're saying
about it or whether you're just annoyed
by us talking about it do you know what
i will say about bud light seltzer well
refreshing doesn't have a weird
aftertaste you're close yeah so that's
all true a strangely low amount of
calories also true it's five percent
alcohol you don't realize it yeah it's
true oh you like cane sugar you like
that's also true oh man i don't know
this is exactly how i would wrap all
those things up all of which are true
statements that you just made here's the
bottom line why it's unquestionably good
hello hello
[Music]
are you crazy now with the kids in
quarantine just homeschooling all day
that's what i picture yeah that's what
we're doing we're like uh i just i only
have one kid but it's that's plenty yeah
there's one more than i want to teach it
feels like you have more now yeah and
it's just like he looks at me like
you know i don't respect you why would i
do why would i listen to you you're not
my teacher you're not my teacher and i'm
sure you know less
i know that you don't know as much i've
see yeah you have no authority over me
yeah
how old now charlie how how old is oh
he's eight
he's eight eight years old yeah and he's
huge by the way this is it right we're
in it it's begun uh yeah i think that
that that was it all right that was big
yeah grace lee fell in
that was great he's uh he's eight years
old and he's uh
wow and he's giants and um
what do you mean not you mean for an
eight-year-old for an eight-year-old
yeah oh really
so last night he doesn't really sleep on
our bed never really has but like
he's kind of been angling for it
recently and so we're like all right you
know what i'll bring you in last night
he was fully sideways across the bed and
he was the full length of it
and we both like at one point i was like
ah screw this like went downstairs to
sleep in his bed i start to get in
my elizabeth's like hey i'm in here so
we both had left
oh that's funny and then i had to wake
him up be like hey man you gotta go back
to your bed
like you gone down like a half hour
earlier
that's really funny yeah
funny i wonder why now that he's into
that now i wonder why you know what i i
think there is like a little bit of
like regressing or something that
they're going through to just like cope
with this
you know a little bit of like wanting to
feel
safe and contained because the world is
unpredictable i don't know what's
happening you know yeah i wonder how
much of that he's absorbing i mean like
it's hard to tell but it's got to be
some i mean you know you stop going to
school and
what has it been now on lockdown like 57
58 days something like that so to an
eight-year-old what does that feel like
that feels like totally that's like a
summer
yeah yeah yeah so how do they explain it
to them as somebody without kids like
what is that is there a protocol do they
do does the school tell you like here's
some guidelines on how to address this
not really because nobody knows right
you know
true
that's true who's gonna be the authority
on that yeah yeah they're like when i
had a pandemic yeah it's like only like
110 year olds uh who knew the spanish
flu was like yeah tell you how to do it
well here's what you do yeah everybody
dies and if you're one of the lucky ones
you go on
and then you go through uh a bunch of
wars
and uh and if you get the vapors you
take a little cocaine
for the papers
you have awesome elixirs if you get sick
yeah they're full of good tips like that
yeah um how have you been seeing your
parents uh you've been facetiming a lot
with them are they are then are they
still in where are they are they they're
in rhode island yeah they're in rhode
island uh i've not been face timing with
them because they're not good on
technology although they did tell me the
other day that they have been doing it
with my sister so i was like well why
didn't
that's fine well then i'll do it with
you they're selectively good
yeah yeah yeah yeah they figured it out
it depends who we're talking to
it depends on which face we want to see
right
some faces need a lot less time
i was trying to remember i was going
back before we did this podcast and i
was trying to remember when we first met
because i actually can't remember it i
remember
you know sometimes
one of the selfish reasons i love doing
this is because i have such a poor
memory and i rely on
people like you who i'm catching up with
to tell me all right here's what here's
what i recall yeah i i remember you
being at williamstown to do hotel
baltimore yeah and you were an
apprentice then right my last year is my
last year the non-act program so i've
been there like four summers oh wow and
that was my i know that place was just
heaven on earth it's the best yeah yeah
we talk about it a lot here but i can't
remember i feel like i knew you before
that but maybe i didn't maybe i knew of
you it must have been williamstown you
were there with um
logan and jimmy jimmy simpson that group
of nonex was crazy so it was like yeah
me sterling brown catherine hahn jimmy
simpson uh logan marshall green
it's crazy yeah wait wait i didn't know
catherine hahn was there then yeah or
maybe she was there the summer before
but that program was really wow i
remember back then
i don't know if you showed it to me then
or this is later jimmy showed it to me
um some of the stuff you were working on
like the shorts you were making just
like the homemade stuff that yeah
becoming
uh it's always sunny is that where that
started or was it even before then yeah
i think jimmy and i started making home
movies uh there oh another guy in that
program was david hornsby who you know
with us since the beginning of sunny
and so i think with jimmy and david and
i would make a lot of like sort of funny
home movies up there and then jimmy and
i lived together in new york right and
we started making just crazy videos
running around like the lower east side
there yeah i remember those i i those
were so good yeah they're pretty pretty
whacked out and that's quite it was one
of the reasons why rob came to me with
glenn with sonny when he was like okay i
got this idea for a show
and i know you make crap
yeah
yeah it was always really good but i
remember thinking
what do you do with it like how does
this then become a show
rob was already an established right
actor rob was in like i think it wasn't
rob in the ice storm and
oh yeah yeah rob rob was working and
yeah i mean everyone was working oh yeah
so they popped up but the original those
original movies they were never
the joy of them was it was like
pre-youtube and it was before everyone
was like trying to make a thing to make
something of themselves so like we were
just doing it to entertain ourselves
like what was the what would make us
laugh and you know usually involved
wearing a lot of wigs and fake teeth and
stuff
yes they were like um they were mine
they were a little bit like the stella
shorts remember uh yeah
yeah you were working too a lot you were
doing tons of commercials right yeah
starter commercials and yeah just like
whatever part of law and order part on
i had like a recurring role on third
watch yeah oh really who was that who
were you on third oh it was mikey
boscarelli i was the uh
i was the junkie younger brother of one
of the cops oh
like bosco was like one of the main cops
then he'd have to arrest me like mikey
you gotta stop but i can't stop
you gotta stop mikey
don't tell me what to do
yeah yeah you're not part of my family
anymore that kind of stuff
but like at the time i mean it's funny
laughing about it but like i remember
those times that you get a job back then
like that and it's like oh [ __ ] this is
it you know it was crazy when i got that
when i got the call for that job it was
september 11th
and then weirdly that day i got like a
phone call from my manager he's like hey
charlie great news
oh my god oh god it was like one of
those mixed things we're like uh that's
that's great um i mean
will there be
filming again uh
which is not too uncommon from the way
this started to feel when it popped up
or yeah i bet
but anyways it was just one of those
surreal things
you know i i've never met your
parents but i read that they were a
music teacher your mom was a
piano teacher and your your dad taught
music history
was your home life just
music constantly just
you know no i mean uh
there was music but there was like
someone's like trying to figure out a
sonata on the piano and like stumbling
through it it wasn't like the von trapps
no no
i mean i definitely remember like
we used to drive to philly to see my
grandma every christmas and they would
be like hey now let's all sing together
and you know i think past like five
years older come on man here we go again
but uh but
now i mean
they were more sort of uh
you know bookie type uh
sort of intellectual type
yeah book it not bookies not like yeah
yeah a lot of operas
where in rhode island did you grow up
charlie do you know what it was
a little bit yeah i used to go to summer
camp in um narragansett uh okay yeah at
a place called yagoog at yaguski valley
yeah it was called yagoog it was a boy
scout camp um in hopes hope valley yeah
there's a there's like one hill in rhode
island that they have like a ski slope
called yahoo
but um or maybe it's technically
connecticut i'm not sure but uh no i
grew up um
on the same island where newport is so
the next town over is called middletown
so i just grew up in middletown
oh you grew up in an island
yeah so uh you know you know newport
rhode island a little bit yeah so
newport and middletown and portsmouth
are the three towns on equinick island
so yeah technically an island but
there's bridges everywhere so it doesn't
totally feel like an island were you did
you do a lot of like maritime things as
a kid like clamming and stuff no
no uh you know that was a real rich guy
thing you know okay all right the boat
the boating the boating folk where like
they come into the summer with their
salmon pants and they're like
lock jaws
what is that thing i don't know it's
like a mid-atlantic i mean is it part of
the way you present yourself all
buttoned up i dated a girl whose family
was all like that seems like a it's like
a paralysis of the lower jaw where
yeah it's lockjaw they're all they've
all stepped on rusty yeah
from like copper from all the coins
you're so rich or something yeah
and coins are made of copper i don't
know a question yeah sure
um no my
my upbringing is funny when i listen to
your podcast they sound similar you know
like uh yeah little league and just
running around with kids in the
neighborhood and yeah did you want to
act i mean do you want do you have
dreams back then of doing this
i knew i i liked it and i knew i had
like a little bit of a knack for it like
uh
it was comfortable doing a school play
or whatever it was um
and seemed to always be able to
you know get a laugh from the audience
on a line or something like that so that
felt natural but no i was all about
baseball i was like okay i'm gonna oh
yeah i'm gonna be amazing
but i think that was more just because
that's what my buddies were doing and so
i sort of
wanted you know i think i wanted to be
more normal i was the son of the two
music teachers and i was like well let
me oh they taught in the school in your
school my mom taught in my school
until i switched schools so i went to a
little private school that she taught at
and then i was like i can't take this
anymore and i switched to the public
school it was too many lock jaws there
too many lock jaws i was much happier at
the public school with all my
neighborhood friends me too yeah yeah
similar i had a similar yeah uh
did kids around that time
i i don't know how to ask this without
that and i you know i i love your voice
everyone loves your voice but
did you notice it were you aware of
your voice your voice i was not aware of
it till i i think like
the first or second season of sunny
was when
you know when someone would write
right i mean in my mind i sound like
james earl jones or someone you know
like
yeah
you know i i think uh
i was not aware that it was a thing
yeah yeah my voice you mean my the
morgan freeman is it too much like
morgan is it too deep for you are
you no i was not even completely unaware
uh and then actually that's not totally
true i mean i think maybe up at
williamstown
you know i think there was like a
a a director or two that was like is
there anything else you can do with your
voice
well what do you mean
i never really thought of it and still
don't totally think of it as all that
unique um i guess i always spoke like
that but well that's a good thing i mean
nor should you i mean it's not the kind
of thing uh if you were to dwell on it
you would probably like maybe play it up
or lean it or whatever you know it's
probably best that you're just like i
know that occasionally i see it rub some
people the wrong way oh really
yeah yeah i remember there's some
reviewer in detroit who's really got it
off of me oh really
come on i can't help this what am i
supposed to do about it yeah
get a voice voice box transplant
specifically your voice he comments on
yeah yeah yeah
there's like a couple nasty reviews of
like this is the worst person ever i
like rip my ears off or something like
come on man come on dude
i um
i just okay man
i remember once and i may have told this
story here before you know josh hamilton
you know josh uh
josh and i were doing a play at
williamstown and we were leaving and it
was uh it was a two-person play uh
british play about
friendship like a real deep friendship
over the course of several years and um
and we were
walking you know how pretty it is there
we were sort of like strolling slowly
and we were behind this old couple and
we were
not knowing how exactly to get around
them and not really wanting to we were
just kind of talking ourselves so we
were walking at a very slow pace right
behind them and we could hear them
talking about the play that our play
that they had just seen
and uh
we i i felt like i needed to stop them
and let them know that we were there
just because they were saying mean
things they were like ah
um
i think i thought they were saying mean
things and so we started walking around
them and i said hey sorry
we're sorry we're just and they said oh
yes you were in the play we just saw it
and we said yeah yeah i couldn't help
myself i said
what what what did you think and
and then in in the sweetest voice
possible in this tone i'm not
exaggerating
ah we have seen everything here since
you know nico's papalapalas whatever
started this
stage in the 50s we saw tennessee
williams workshop we've seen every
single thing main stage
and this was easily the worst thing
we've ever seen
and josh and i were laughing of course
and we were like oh why and
oh it was enough with and they said
enough with all the gay stuff
which we also made us laugh because we
were like well
you have a whole other agenda here yes
yes yes yeah
but it was uh but it's funny the way she
delivered that news it wasn't like
you know it was just so
earnest and
there was no sense that she might be
hurting our feelings or something uh
yeah yeah yeah but it's true that's all
you read on the internet i mean that's
what right on the internet it's that
conversation and they don't know that
they're hurting your feelings because
right they don't think that you're gonna
read it right i mean
i don't know you're a teenage kid
somewhere in ohio when you write
something nasty about sean penn you
really think sean penn's going to be
sifting through all your comments well
he might be he might be bored that day
he might poke it around if i know sean
he probably is
hey listen harry potter fan 29
you little [ __ ] i worked very
hard in this role
i i didn't have a lot of time to prepare
for mystic river um
it's something like it's always sunny
are you still aware of what people are
saying about it do you or you do try to
tune it out um
no i try to tune it out mostly and i
mean i think
sometimes if we put an episode out that
i'm really excited about i might yeah
check it out like uh
last season for fun we did one like
entirely in the style of a film noir oh
yeah i've heard about this yeah yeah as
i was curious i was like well i just
want to see what the reception is but
yeah
outside of like a little bit of
masochistic poking around i i want you
to you know and did that has that
changed the more comfortable confident
you've gotten in the show and now the
show is just i mean to say it's taken
off
i mean in the beginning i read
everything yeah you know and by the way
in the beginning everything was bad yeah
oh really you mean the reviews yeah
oh the reviews were terrible
and i i even had i think it was in the
either new york or new york times an
early reviewer write a review 10 years
later saying that they were wrong which
is really rare oh wow yeah have you ever
they did that with the big lebowski
which was a movie that just got pretty
much banned when it when it came out and
they went back and there were all these
reviewers that were like
yes i didn't get it at the time all
right missing out on this and it was
pretty great to see
pretty much across the board the ones
that were like hey yeah i acknowledge
this great movie but there was still
like one or two holdouts that we're like
no no no
this movie is not very good i stand by
it
uh oh all right do you direct a lot of
the sunny episodes now
no
no uh i i've not done any of them um
when you're show running you're you're
making a lot of the decisions the
director would make you know you're
picking the prop and you're choosing the
cast and
uh you're okaying the locations and
especially now that we've been doing it
so long we can give a lot of people an
opportunity by giving them a directing
spot so i kind of don't want to take one
of those up
and then also
stylistically i think it's not really
what i would want to do as a director so
i'm happy
you do want to direct something you want
to direct things yeah actually just i'm
just finishing up a film oh no kidding
and i wrote and directed and
i'm really excited about i got a great
cast i got
ken jong and kate beckinsale and talking
about [ __ ] ray liotta my taco oh my god
uh bateman does a little thing for me
and jillian bell uh
oh my god um
adrian brody it's i guess it's really
great sort casper like um it's a
hollywood satire
it's sort of an homage to being there to
see the movie oh yeah oh my god i love
that movie yeah um well what an eclectic
cast jesus yeah you know it's
i'm just really flattered that so many
people were willing to do it uh but it's
been a real process trying to get it
done
you mean with the quarantine with the
quarantine and i'd finished it but i had
to go deliver another season of sunny so
i had to jump out of the editing room
and back in and then i
tried to rush some cuts out but it
wasn't done and then i was just about
ready to finish and the quarantine
happened so
i've been talking with my editor on the
phone daily and she's been doing cuts
and sending them to me it's crazy that's
what we've been doing with our editor in
l.a we've just been doing it on zoom
we're at the stage now we're chipping
away to in such a specific you know
well you know you know i've been doing i
thought about the zoom thing and i
thought i think it's actually gonna be
better for me to just be very specific
about
certain areas of it and then just let
her do her thing and then send it back
to me and it's actually been a good
process i'm starting to wonder if i'll
always want to cut like this which is
because i think it just it it
it doesn't allow for us as much second
guessing and nitpicking which you can
really spiral out in the editing so
funny we were just saying yeah yeah
we're just saying that yeah if you have
the luxury of seeing everything
yeah you go crazy in there sometimes um
so
it allows me to kind of have an opinion
on it and step away then come back have
an opinion on it and i feel like since
we've been doing this i've had a clear
look and vision
at the movie that i have months before
what's the what's the goal with it
charlie i mean obviously to have people
see it but what where are you are you
planning on
film festivals and stuff
i don't well i mean not anymore
sorry that was a question from
pre-quarantine
we wrote these a while ago yeah but uh i
mean i think uh are you having a lot of
people over your house to watch it
i think
i think those days are gonna be on hold
for a little bit so i think as soon as i
get this cut done i'll probably start
just
slipping it around town and seeing if
someone wants to buy it and distribute
it hopefully probably a streaming
service since i don't know when we're
going back to the movie theaters
life could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vibed for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wondering plus in
apple podcasts or the wandery app
[Music]
hello hello again
[Music]
did you meet sedakiss on going the
distance was that when i'm happy we
segued in and going to the gym yeah yeah
because they got a lot to say about it
oh you do or are you being sarcastic no
oh i do yeah
that was a great experience for me you
know it was before i had a kid and so it
was just like
i didn't have that guilt of being away
working so you know we were in new york
and they were putting me up in a hotel
and um
right mary elizabeth yeah wasn't she she
did i think she came out for a little
bit maybe but
i did yeah she did a picture she did a
bit in it yeah with with pratt right
with chris pratt yes yes that was that
was later that was a pick-up shoot oh
okay i think
but uh it's funny they cut chris pratt
like oh guys going nowhere you got
nothing going nowhere not a good car
really carry the screens right
right yeah tough to look
yeah um
that was such a
fun movie for me once they got past the
first week of thinking they were gonna
fire me because
that was my first studio film
no [ __ ] yeah before that it was all
unwatchable horror movies or whatever or
tv um no [ __ ] and you know what i did i
refused to audition for it because
i don't know i knew i knew you and i
knew the director liked me and yeah and
i knew the writer really wanted me yeah
i don't recall there being any
hesitation with any of us i might be
wrong no i i think maybe it was just
like the studio was like well let's see
him on tape and i figured if i give him
a reason to kind of have it ha
he'll probably say no so i'm like just
either go or don't go and then because i
didn't audition i thought all right if
they're unhappy with what they're seeing
on daily lives they're going to can me
oh that's see that's why that's why it's
tough to when you don't i mean it's
ballsy to not audition but in this case
it makes sense sometimes it makes sense
yeah yeah sometimes it makes sense not
too rarely but yeah but every now and
then you're in a position where
you don't necessarily need the job and
you know everyone wants you you're just
going to give them a reason to because
the audition everyone knows it's not
it's so different from actually being in
a scene it's such a crazy process i
don't think i was ever really great at
it i i'm
saying i just had this experience where
i i made a tape i was like i i hammed in
hot a little bit about making the tape
because it was a director that i was
like
i don't need to work with that you know
it's not the
they weren't releasing the script it was
really like it was real secretive and i
was like fine the sides weren't great
the agents said oh they really like you
they want you just make a tape
everyone's doing it so i made a tape
fine i mean i don't have you know that
much else to do made the tape and um oh
they like you so much they need you to
read another scene
and that's when i was like oh [ __ ] are
you okay come on watch something it
wasn't
yeah and i did i did i made another tape
another scene and i didn't get it
yeah that's that's like that's right
you've done that yeah yeah
i should have done what you did um but
we should clarify that you had already
been doing it's always sunny for for
years i think we were in our fifth
season already yeah and it had taken off
we were about to do that big tour where
we like we're doing the live theaters
that's right or we had just on air we
were about to do it something like that
but
but i i remember go i have a couple of
really great memories from that movie
one was
the first rehearsal i think we all did
and sedakis was there
and
he must have been wiped out because he
was like out at snl really late or
something
and he's just
sideways on the couch not not facing us
and i just remember his shorts and for
whatever reason i remember the guy's
butt
i don't know if he was ripping farts or
whatever whatever was happening but he
was like maybe a little hungover
yeah he had that mustache and i was like
i like this guy immediately yes i
immediately like this guy
yeah talk about not showing any like
nerves or any said he just felt like he
belonged he was acting like he's
confident confident guy yeah and he did
belong there i mean it was like there
was no reason he shouldn't be confident
but that was fun because i you know we
would film a lot but then we would go
out and hang out afterwards yeah and
party yeah and uh i remember once is it
okay to talk about oh please yeah again
selfishly like this is great because my
memory i just remember having a lot of
fun i got a great memory so
one of my favorite memories of that is
um we're at your uh you and you had like
a hotel suite at the
at the bowery
battery hotel yet yeah we're there we're
hanging out and uh you know we've been
drinking a lot
and
there was a
female actress who's in the movie
i won't name names
and
somehow somehow she got in her head that
she wanted to have a punching contest
with drew
i don't know
how or why she got this idea
but out of the blue she's like let's
have a punching contest and i'm thinking
you know she was maybe fairly young and
like
like i was like she was gonna kill this
girl i don't know what you're messing
with you don't understand so i think she
was like yeah this sounds [ __ ] great
oh yeah oh and i bet she agreed in a
heartbeat oh yeah go ahead punch my arm
so the girl punched drew's arm and she's
like oh pretty good and then it was true
and drew
punched this girl so hard in the arm
that from her shoulder to her elbow in
like 45 minutes she had a bruise that
looked exactly like africa
i mean it was it was the most
well-defined
specific
you can navigate a ship in the ocean
according to this
is that cape horn it was an
instantaneous uh-huh i've never seen a
body just going
oh man
i don't know why i remember that so well
i remember the look on her she when she
would yeah she'd get really she'd get
because what drew does she does
everything with like with passion
uh
and that's that was that's no different
oh yeah yeah
she's like she didn't break the uh
whatever that giant arm bone is in there
called
i remember that i remember actually
being surprised by the level of
paparazzi that we're chasing you and
drew around and i'm not right i've not
seen that before uh you know we were
trying to film in central park and they
were kind of everywhere that's right i
remember watching that movie and seeing
them in the shot you can see him in the
shot sometimes oh really yeah so many of
them and uh
yeah
radio man oh driving up that day he's
like a famous new york city uh
i assume he's homeless yeah i've heard
different things about radio man i had
her let's say he carries himself like a
homeless man whether he has a home or
not
homeless adjacent yeah yeah yeah he's a
he's styling something
like daryl leaked
yes he has yeah he has homeless uh
aesthetic
but but i actually think he has i i i
may be wrong about this so we can cut it
up but i think he actually may have a
very nice home
well yeah
i think he came into money
yeah
a funny side note here is uh i think it
might have even been the next year we
were
filming a season of sunny and we were at
the jersey shore doing a jersey shore
episode and we were doing this funny bit
about uh
uh dennis and dee talking about how
great it used to be under the boardwalk
um and how like romantic things happened
down there
and
as they turned the corner there's just
like two homeless guys banging each
other
and
for some reason radio man shows up and
he's he's the he's the recipient of the
banging oh really and yeah
and
we're going to shoot it and to rob
mackelhany's credit he's like no these
guys have to have their pants down i'm
like come on man we can't we can't do
that we can't do that to the actors and
we can't do it but we did it and it's in
the episode
it's one of the more shocking hilarious
moments in the history of the
wait did did radio man play so he played
the receiver of those yeah so
so
whoever you know i don't know how he got
to jersey and he rode his bike to jersey
or something that's what i'm saying i
think he
i think he has real means
yeah i don't think he's riding his bike
everywhere yeah he's got a penthouse and
like uh
park avenue or something yeah i think he
does uh
i don't i think he inherited a lot of
money um
but uh you know i remember speaking of
inheriting money there was a papa
specific paparazzo remember that guy
forgetting his name now i'm glad i don't
want to give him any
i am remembering
you guys having a beef with a specific
guy he was unusually aggressive he knew
all the rules about where he could
because in new york like there aren't
really rules about interrupting shots
and like getting in the middle of
and as you know if you shoot anywhere
else outside la or new york people are
always usually very you know
accommodating if you if with a shoot
like they won't be they won't walk
through or they'll you know they'll go a
little out of their way to walk around
but not in new york and
um
so you have to lock down all these
streets and but there was this one guy
who would get right up to the camera
that was rough i have a vague memory of
that yeah yeah
also
another weird thing about that movie is
do you remember we shot an entire dance
sequence i don't think it's in the film
uh yeah in that bar right in um the
russian
yeah and the russian bar like weirdly
adam shanklin the director who was like
a producer on the movie he produced it
yeah adam adam and his sister jen
produced like directed a dance number
that's right that's right
yeah so no i don't know why uh it was a
wonderful great dance yeah uh
how is that film for you looking back on
it like are there regrets about it
because it didn't do well in the box
office and no i i've got past that i've
um i think i've gone having said that i
know i'm like well it would have been
really nice if it had done well only
because i think it would have
it would have led to things that then
went away as soon as that movie i
remember right before it came out um
there were all these things that were
you know i
you and jason for example were already
in horrible bosses but that was
something that
one an example of something that they
were talking about me for you know what
i mean and i can remember that yeah and
a couple other things you know where it
was like
oh wow you're gonna have some nice
things to choose from
and then
the next week after that movie came out
it was like uh
crickets you know do you feel like that
puts you in movie jail for a little bit
yeah i think it did there was such a
stark difference between the week before
with the
options that were available and being
talked about to
charlie like having a hard time getting
my agent on the phone that's crazy man i
feel free with that because
probably it was a combination of a few
things right they think uh i think back
then there was more of a perception if
if a movie doesn't open and you're out
in front then you get you you get the
blame for it but you know it was just a
few years later that
pretty much all those movies bit by bit
started dying off box office wise as
superhero movies were pumping up and
people are spending less and less you
know they're
like a few last little bursts over the
next like five years of yeah how many
movies that hit and then yeah to the
point where they just stopped opening
and well romantic comedies especially is
a tricky one yeah that genre had not
been doing well uh i don't regret this
at all i loved working with drew i'm
glad we got to do that i'll forever be
grateful for that experience but i think
um
i think there may have been because
like you said there was a lot of
paparazzi around i think people may have
just been sick of
either sick of
maybe sick of us or
just like oh i can see them in in this
shitty magazine why would i watch a
movie where they're
um no i think you're right i mean i
think there is an
aspect to that where
you know your relationship was being so
covered by the press that you're burning
you're burning an audience out right um
because i feel like most people are
annoyed by those articles you know um
especially the people that they're being
written about but like right yeah but
you know people are like they get they
get burned out on on people so i think
it it yeah it was a bad storm of things
right now if you did that movie on
netflix great yeah no harm no foul
doesn't ding yet you know like but you
could do it for easily for four or five
million dollars and probably would be a
better movie i think so
i think so but i loved working with you
how long after was the horrible bosses
then it was shortly after right i feel
like it was maybe the next year i think
so yeah yeah and it's funny because i
wasn't so sure about horrible bosses at
first because i
the script you know was good but it
wasn't like uh i didn't realize maybe
how likeable the movie was going to be
or like how uh likable's not the right
word but i just didn't realize it was
going to work as well as it did like
accessible yeah accessible like you know
i i think i signed on first i had no
idea the cast that they were going to
get so as far as you know you're signing
on to something and they put like the
wrong bosses and it's
a real stinker it's a horrible cast
yeah yeah i'm not going to name names
but there's
you know what as those bosses
yeah but they get instead they get like
an amazing cast
so you know that was just one of those
[ __ ] things and so did that change
everything i mean in the way that going
the distance shuts doors does a movie
like that right away do you see doors
open it's hard to tell right because
that's the thing when you're in it do
you ever really know that the doors are
opening and shutting i mean maybe
maybe
some people have an experience where oh
my god the phone's ringing like crazy
and it's it's everyone for me it's just
been so bit by bit building it up you
know and with little bursts like when
studying caught on it was a burst but
not so much of a burst that we were on
the cover of every magazine and stuff
like that you know what year was that
charlie i'm trying to remember when i
started seeing billboards for it like
consistently well we started in 2005 and
then um
you know they started probably doing
billboards around the third fourth
season yeah i mean they had a few season
two but i think it caught on around
season five season six yeah yeah with
the horrible bosses it was
it was fun to know you were in a movie
that was like a hit it was a box office
success and
uh for the most part critically liked
but it didn't really like certainly my
phone wasn't ringing off the hook i mean
it was kind of ringing off the hook with
[ __ ] stuff like just being like i'm
gonna make sure you're like the you know
biggest star everybody like
you never hear from the guy again right
all right man i changed my number
i was really high when i texted it i
don't know
on account of my inability to actually
achieve that
i texted all my clients that yeah yeah
sorry i meant to send that to stanley
well and he already was the biggest star
but i wanted him to give me credit for
it
i know after that you did you started
doing really huge movies guillermo del
toro you get to work with him that was a
cool one i bet what was that like doing
pacific rim oh man that was great but
you know that really came through sunny
uh because guillermo was a big sunny fan
no [ __ ] yeah and he's actually been on
the show three times what yeah yeah oh
that's funny we've had him on a few
times oh my god and we had like a little
exchange going where he's like i give
you the part you give me a part okay and
uh uh
so
oh he plays himself no he plays uh
he plays papi mcboyle uh who's like
jimmy simpson's father
that was a great experience because uh i
hadn't done anything like that just a
movie of that scale yeah and you know
guillermo is um
is a real artist yeah
so his just attention to detail and
you know one of the things that blew my
mind was
there was one sequence where i'm running
from one of these monsters and they've
leveled four city blocks of hong kong
that was all something they built
indoors and there's rain machines and
god and i'm trying to get out of the
rain machine between takes and uh i step
inside one of the little restaurants
that i'm running past and i go about 10
tables back and there's a menu and it's
covered in blue fingerprints and one of
the things gamma would come up with or
whoever had come up with was that uh
that the monsters like you know leave
blue oohs and stuff everywhere so the
idea that whoever had been in that
restaurant had been holding the menu
with their blue fingers that detail and
the camera was never going to see it
it was never going to see it but wow so
so it was a combination of like
wonderful artistic attention to detail
and then sometimes chaos where you know
he would girl would say okay you're
going to run this way and i'm going to
flip a car over your head do not trip
you will die
wait what
okay
by the way it's a 17 hour reset so don't
screw up the shot
god oh my god you know just
crazy stuff
a radio man strolls onto set
yeah
by the way i was being electrocuted that
for that entire shoot i didn't realize
it so i'm wearing this like honey i
shrunk the kids kind of headset thing
that makes me mind-meld with these
monsters yeah and every time i put it on
it's it's really like it feels like
there's a sharp edge just going right
into my ear and i keep looking for the
edges i can't find it
but i don't want to say anything and i
don't i don't want to be like the actor
who's complaining he's got a weird thing
so uh so you know i'm just kind of
gritting my teeth through it and then
there's a scene where my where where
burn gorman has to put it on and he puts
it on he's like oh [ __ ] man it's
electrocuting me
i'm
i'm like oh that that's what that is
that's what that is that's electricity
shooting into my ear you look like bride
of frankenstein your hair's off
my teeth are glowing at night
i didn't feel anything
and i also want to ask you about uh
uh fist fight oh yeah because i love a
good odd couple comedy was that always
going to be ice cube was he already
signed on to it
no um
so i i appreciated
and like uh
and had gotten richie keane who is the
sunny director uh attached to it and um
actually we might have had cube before
that but the studio it was a studio's
idea to bring cube on and i thought look
i love ice cubes so
great i'm i'm in um
but that was a really
grueling shoot i really like it yeah
because we shot that fight
and you know everything that the stunt
guys did they wanted us to do as well at
least to take off like with the
exception of like
you know getting dragged by a horse and
like one other thing
but
but it's not like any like when i got
dragged i got dragged by a golf cart you
know like
you got dragged by a mule we were just
beating the crap out of each other
shooting that fight sequence for
something like two weeks straight you
know you're going 14-hour days fighting
all day every day and by the way i
wasn't in great condition because i'm
supposed to be a weakling teacher right
i'm not supposed to be like some ripped
guy
right i still am a little bit of pain
from that movie and i think it was about
six years ago yeah i have like daily hit
pain which started on that movie well
i'm glad i brought it up well you know
uh it's i just want to get it on tape
for the lawsuit today
i'm kidding i'm not going to steal i
want to work
[Laughter]
but it also was just so fun i mean like
you know tracy morgan and camille did a
bit and oh yeah julian bell and
oh yeah it was a good it was a good time
oh good and and do you still have do you
still talk to cube i love that you
may be closer i in my fantasy you're
friends with him no i'm friendly with
him but uh it's been a minute since i
talked to him i think we would email
each other you know or the occasional
text no it was great it was it was like
it was a hilarious group of actors it
was a
creators yeah
really good experience oh charlie man i
i i really miss talking to you this is
funny i know man i really appreciate you
doing this there just a couple quick i
have uh like a lightning round oh you
want to get right into the lightning
let's do it um there's something else i
was going to ask you uh i know i feel
like i had one other great go in the
distance memory but uh yeah i
yeah you rarely broke uh
i remember you doing that stuff on the
toilet
it was hard to get through it was really
hard to get through because you were so
i'm just ridiculous you're sitting on
the toilet and you're
you're like wiping your hand i remember
rolling i didn't remember you wrapping
your hand up with the toilet paper
that surprisingly on me i've gotten a
lot worse about breaking oh oh really
yeah i can i can't get through five
minutes with glenn howerton on sunny
like oh yeah i bet but but you know uh
i think maybe i didn't want to get fired
so i was having extra focus there's
pressure yeah you're you're
you're focused um
is it still is it hard still coming up
you've been it's always sunny it's been
on for what fifteen
what yeah
seasons yeah jesus god um
is it hard coming up now with
epic story lines and episodes so hard
that's repeating ourselves you know god
damn it sounds like you're still as
involved in the writing process yeah oh
yeah no i mean i think um
especially the last season i think uh
rob and i specifically really kind of
made an effort to make sure we
worked a little
extra hard on each script so that you
know that you don't want to just you
don't want to get lazy and start phoning
it in because
if if an episode doesn't turn out great
like
it feels worse than noah than me you
know like right right that's the worst
feeling is feeling like you haven't made
something good so we're still
really pushing ourselves to just do our
best how did you get danny devito
because back then i don't think people
appreciate how like lo-fi the show was
when it started out either he'd seen her
fx sent him in the first season but his
kids loved it so his kids were like oh
this is great
um
and then john landgraf who runs fx had
worked with danny at jersey
pictures or films
so they were buddies and then
the third part was cash i mean they they
paid him
he likes cash he likes cash they made
like a ton of money for 15 days of work
and then oh really yeah we shot all his
stuff first and then we went and shot
the rest of the season oh my god
no [ __ ] yeah uh it's great that you can
do that i guess that's that's the way
it's set up yeah because he's always in
the bar right yeah well we we kind of
shoot it like a couple big movies like
we used to do it in chunks of five at a
time so like five episode blocks and
yeah
oh my god that must require a lot of
planning and a lot of toughest on the
crew yeah it's like if you have a bruise
in one scene and then you're switching
to an episode where you don't then you
go back and you got to remember and you
got to plan it out so that you're not
like
you know in the makeup chair so long
putting bruise on taking it off yeah
yeah yeah life could be a dream
[Music]
what's your most commonly used emoji
would you say it's probably just uh a
nice yellow thumbs up you know
real gender neutral with it i'm like i'm
so scared about the world that i won't
even i won't even make my thumbs up
white because i'm like i don't want that
to seem insensitive or
yes yes yes i know i don't want to be
accused of anything so yeah i have a
homer simpson though
and and now the white because there are
then different shades like darker shades
obviously so the white white one looks
really white it looks like [ __ ] airy
nation i'm very uncomfortable with the
thumb shades
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play
and why i think you know growing up it
would have been baseball but i'm such a
golf junkie now i think it would be golf
i'd be as a professional golfer yeah you
played second base charlie i did
depending on how good the team was like
if the team was okay i played second
base if the team was really good i was
way out in the right field uh-huh yeah i
i was only in right field or i was a
base coach
were you good enough to have played in
college did you aspire to play in
college i did but you know what i i
tried to walk onto my college's team and
i didn't make the cut and then i right
after that i was like i'm gonna go sign
up for theater and like i was like this
is a much better fit that's similar to
my yeah this makes a lot more sense what
was your thing was football yeah i
wanted to be a football i wanted to play
so badly and um and that's when i did a
similar thing where it was like ah
uh i better better try better tread the
boards
yeah um
i used to think it was my size i used to
be like well you know what i mean it was
i'm i'm like five six and three quarters
it's not realistic but then this altuve
guy comes along in the astros he's
making me look good uh charlie if you
could have one snack food for the rest
of your life what would it be i don't
know that it counts as a snack food but
i'll i'll put hot sauce on anything
so
it's funny did you have you done that um
hot sauce talk show no you did that i
did that and i it's actually pretty
funny and the host
really
knows his stuff and does a good
interview but um i mean i at the time i
was in the middle of a press junket i'm
like what am i on i'm on some hot show
now you know so i think maybe i'd have
the best attitude about it but i i
realized i've been training for it for
years because i was like i put all yours
in everything
yeah it's fine yes fine next question
uh this is the atomic what now yeah i
mean my eyes still water my nose runs
but i like i thoroughly enjoyed it
well i i that's to me is insane i i'm
the opposite not not the opposite i i
like a little bit of spice but i can't
whenever it becomes it gets in the way
of the flavor or the food that i'm
eating i i don't know how that happened
to me out in california i i was not a
hot sauce guy until i came out here and
then
started putting the top tio on
everything and yeah now i'm hooked
did they keep upping the ante do they
keep giving you like spices that's not
worse they get increasingly hot it's a
pretty funny show to watch because
you're trying to answer questions
seriously and at a certain point you
become high from the heat oh my god
and it's probably like vanity wise not
the best
is this probably [ __ ] coming out of your
orifices yeah most of my videos a while
ago
that was pre williamstown it's still in
there a little bit but yeah
i remember in fact speaking of vanity
and comedy after
go and sandler after going the distance
i was at shankman
so this is adam shank when we were
talking about the choreographer invited
me it was it was right after god i think
it was just after the movie opened and
bombed
so i was a little bummed and uh
had i known what it meant career-wise i
would have been like devastated but at
the time i was like well on to the next
you know
well i i think time will write this
wrong for you my friend uh well yeah
first of all you're great in the movie
and you're far too talented to go to any
movie jail for too long so wow right you
get the right gig well yeah i mean it's
not but but at the time it was like oh
[ __ ] uh but it was the weekend i think
after that i think it came out at the
end of the summer and it was a labor day
party uh i think it was shankman's i
think the shangman's out in like palm
springs where anyway there were a lot of
fancy people there and adam sandler was
there and he goes hey buddy i saw that
uh
i saw the movie you did with drew um
and uh
yeah yeah you were good but you know
your body buddy your body you um that's
not a comedy body
and and i said what do you what do you
mean he goes no no you did you work out
for that and and i was embarrassed to
say that i had i i like of course you're
playing the handsome leading guy like
and you know i think drew is so pretty
that i like wanted to
i wanted to look as good as i could and
um
and he said yeah yeah you shouldn't do
that buddy it's uh nobody wants to laugh
at a guy who's ripped
yeah well this is right there is some
truth to that but yeah
ben stiller was always weirdly ripped
anytime he popped his shirt off you'd be
like wow you're in great shape man and
always funny and everything he ever did
uh of course always funny questions to
the rule that's true that's true but
true or false whenever you'd see like
i'm thinking of that scene and meet the
parents when they're in the volley
they're playing pool volleyball yeah
yeah there was always like a moment
where you're like oh whoa
like really handsome like i don't know
if i feel that bad for him now it's true
yeah no no sandler's right i mean like
i thought about this too before where i
was like i bet if i got really fat it
would like help my career but
i can't do it like i said the vanity's
in there are enough right right in there
or like mclaney like when rob got
and he was inarguably
much funnier in the seasons where he got
really fat and the reason where he got
really fat he's really funny he's still
heating that season yeah and then the
seasons where he got really ripped he's
still very good it's just not as funny
it's just so fun
i'll tell you what that is that is
because
what we like about funny people is
it makes us feel better about the things
that we feel insecure about in ourselves
right so that we're like oh if that
person can
be succeeding in the movie in the in
their life and whatever
as a seemingly regular person
then the parts of me that i feel like
aren't
uh a supermodel status i think are okay
you know so that's interesting i think
we identify with that we don't we don't
want our funny guys ripped i get a lot
of shame for this and i'm br i braced
myself for it what's your favorite movie
of all time and i thought about this
because it's like let me ask you do you
actually have a favorite movie i i think
if i gunned to my head and i had to say
one and i'm hooked up to some sort of
lie detector i think it would probably
be
back to the future oh wow um just
because it you know what it is and we've
been modifying it to say
the the most comforting or the one that
you would watch i thought about that
because you're not asking someone to say
what movie do you think is the best
movie ever made exactly right you're
saying what movie could you sit down and
watch any day of the week because you
like it that much i think for me it is
the levesque big lebowski anytime i go
to pop that on i enjoy it thoroughly and
yeah watch it it's in its entirety me
too whenever it's on tv i'm flipping
around i it's one of those movies and
there are so few
like this but i have to keep watching it
yeah jerry o'connell said that he was
very close to getting phil hoffman's
part in that
and it really freaked me out because i
imagining eric still says marty mcfly
like that movie is so as this big
lebowski is so familiar to me that the
idea of anyone else doing
anything i think everybody is close to a
part until phil hoffman walks in the
room right
you're no longer close to the park yeah
game over yeah
that's so good
uh
if you had to live somewhere else where
would it be a couple options i mean i
really do
love rhode island i love growing up
there i love it um and i love new york
city i live there but yeah if you're
gonna say you have to live in a place i
think put me in hawaii
right i love hawaii i mean come on i
mean let's avoid the winters right yeah
if you get dinner with three people dead
or alive whom you've never met who would
it be uh i'm gonna you know what i'm
gonna speaking of the coen brothers why
don't i i'll sit down with two that
bites off too yeah so
i sit down and maybe if they have a
third brother
yeah ralph cohen i gotta throw someone
in just to just totally different speed
of energy of a human being here let's
see
um that i never met um
let's throw let's just throw kim jong-un
in there you know
like just to mix it up just the cone
brothers and the dictator of north korea
just to see what is yeah
yeah just to stir the pot just to be
like what do you like what do you like
at dinner what do you like in a like
mundane setting you probably don't speak
in english though i don't know if that
was the right call oh you could have you
could bring a translator as your friend
all right i'll stick with it um you know
sometimes i think about him because i
heard his father and i think it's true
of him too kim jong-il loved hollywood
movies like yeah
knew a lot about movies so do you ever
wonder if like kim jong-un for example
knows who you are
is that weird to think about i've not
thought about that i'm gonna say
doubtful
i think he might i hate to say that um i
don't know if you want him to know who
you are
yeah
sure why not
who's your favorite muppet i got a big
kick out of gonzo uh back in the day i
was a big gonzo fan um
you know hard to beat that gonzo but
there's something about kermit holding
it all together man
holding it all together and he can sing
and he can just he can talk about being
put up and guide us through this chaos
yes yes yes that was really dark when
kermit lost his mind in muppets take
manhattan yeah and you thought he was
somebody else it's like you don't want
to see a dark kermit you don't want to
see a dark tom hanks
dark tom hanks yeah dark superman and
superman 3 was really freaky do you
remember that that was upsetting um
if you could have we're almost done if
you could have one super power uh what
would it be is super intelligence the
superpower yeah sure smartest person
in the world yeah sure you just know
everything somebody said uh which i even
considered i thought was a really good
one
they would just know every language like
c-3po
um
so i i guess you need an app for that
well don't [ __ ] on their choice um
that's um
and i would want to be the smartest
person ever you know first of all from a
superhero standpoint you someone's going
to shoot a laser beam at you but you're
like i already knew you were going to do
that right the scariest person ever from
a life standpoint i guess that was
corona virus messing in a cinch
yeah guys
in your sleep smartest person ever yeah
yeah also by the way then you know every
language presumably yeah
language yeah
uh if you could be reincarnated as a
non-human animal what would you pick
what animal would you identify with i
think i would want to check out flight
right i mean you got to put
some kind of eagle some sort of majestic
eagle yes it'd be nice to see to know
what it's like to feel majestic for for
once
um
and then you know except i wouldn't want
to be ball
all right well you would just have like
a shock of white hair yeah well that's
pretty majestic i mean yeah it can be
majestic yes
yeah uh would you rather be called
unattractive or unfunny unfunny yeah
well you know funny people often say
that one because and i think it's
probably because you know you're funny
yeah because i've gone through life
being funny and it's okay but i bet life
being really attractive would be way
better
like you know well we wouldn't have uh a
lot of great we wouldn't have it's
always sunny we wouldn't have a lot of
great performances um
we would have handsome appreciate that
had some really good handsome
performances my performers favorite
performers are the most handsome ones
that's true that's true
smoldering uh which which golden girl do
you most identify with dorothy blanche
rose or sophia
boy
they're all so great uh i'd love to be a
combination of them all yeah yeah all
the good attributes the fun attributes
of each would be nice you know as a
performer i know there's probably a lot
of rows and like what i do on on
uh wait rose is the dumb one yeah yeah
but
i'm funny you mean but the one that i
respect when i go when i rewatch those
episodes the most that just blows me
away is bea arthur his daughter as
dorothy i mean yeah you know what none
of those jokes land if you don't have
her deadpan reaction totally
every dumb thing that she's stuck in the
middle of yeah i think her she blows me
away man do you miss doing theater are
you a really great theater actor
i don't miss it yeah don't miss it i
miss it in theory like yeah
you know like i missed that time at
williamstown which just a great time in
my life and i missed the community of
doing a play but like right now in my
life the idea of going somewhere to work
so hard for so many a limited amount of
people to see the work yeah feels
right now i think it's just well now a
very limited amount now like yeah maybe
four people yeah two people in math but
uh
i think maybe just because i have a
a young son at home like if i i think uh
later in life i'd like to do it again
but right now
i can't really justify leaving town for
that long no of course or play right it
would feel to me
this is ridiculous right because to go
to a great broadway play would be the
best yeah but right now it would feel
like a vain
selfish move that would hurt my kid but
that's really dumb because it's not i
mean it's
i think that's really admirable i don't
think it's dumb at all i think it means
you are a really committed
parent and this is like of all the time
to leave it's not like he's an infant i
mean eight years old is like a really
formative
yeah i mean
it was a little bit easier to leave and
go to a gig in those first three years
yeah
but now it's like uh especially with all
this going on it's like oh man up and go
again and then you know i know at some
point i'll have to yeah just part of
what we do but uh charlie we can also
cut this out we cut out anything um
and i may be getting this wrong but were
you in the louis ck
movie yeah we don't got this out let's
get into it
what happened to that they just
completely shelved it did something
happen with that
no yeah why didn't that come out no i
know why it didn't i think what happened
was
they so that we went to toronto to
toronto film festival right and
he'd sold it to a distributor
then every you know his whole thing
hit the fan and yeah
you know the whole me too thing and all
that all the stuff was coming out and um
and i think he
bought it back from the distributors he
said here's your money back i'll take it
off your hands wow uh and he just has it
oh oh that was an interesting year for
me in terms of
i had done two projects and i've done
this the sequel to uh
pacific rim that cairo wasn't directing
oh he i didn't know he didn't direct
that he was going to and then i think he
had to go do shape of water and his
schedule didn't work out
he had to go with it
yeah more power to him but um so there
was a different script a different
director and i wasn't so sure about it
but i thought you know what i enjoy
being a part of this franchise it's been
a really great experience for me
i'm gonna stick with it and then i louis
ck called me about this movie and i
thought wow he's working with malkovich
and he's working with eddie falco and
you know he always wins awards for
everything he does and i'm like and i've
not ever been a part of that crew yeah
so i was like okay finally i'm getting
pulled into the group of people that are
sort of critically acclaimed great let
me go do that and then so that one of
course turned out to be a disaster and
the other one turned out
a different disaster i think what's
happening
is supposed to happen right it's like
there's a bit of a social reckoning that
had to happen and it's unfortunate it's
sure [ __ ] messy but
i guess it's it's just
go down that way uh yeah i think any
change any change that seismic is gonna
be
messy um
you know it's i kind of feel like going
back to like the beginning of a
conversation where i feel like i can
feel both things and i'm allowed to feel
both things where
i can be like i enjoyed doing the movie
yeah i liked louis i got to become
friends with john malkovich and edie
falco and they got to do my movie which
is great i think through that and um
and so that was a good experience and i
can also feel bad for the women that had
that happen to them of course and i can
also feel bad for louie that he's ruined
his life clearly he has there's some
sort of problem that he had but
you know
it's a mess that's the one
scary element of this societal change is
that if it changes to the point where
we're not able to
even discuss all of the different
feelings that are encompassed in in that
if there's no room for those different
things yeah that's that's what it is
scary but there is room for discussion
around those i think it was especially
like there wasn't room at the moment but
that makes sense it's like you ever like
you know talk to someone who's like
super pissed about something it's you
got to let them get it out you're like
yes hey
you've been oppressed for all the time
and you don't want to hear my opinion i
get it i get it i'll give you a minute
is my people been doing the impression
[ __ ] my bad i got you i hear you
you don't want to hear a defensive
counter argument right now i'll give you
a minute
yeah okay but but you know i of course
at the same time it does suck to be like
but hey hang on a second i'm not
i'm not doing this stuff you know it's
not me but you know i know but as
me i know it was jesse eisenberg said it
really well on this show he said you
know if that's the price for
this very necessary change that has to
happen if okay if now it's a little
tricky for some guys to now talk about
it or
uh for a little while then so be it
because the overall change is is a net
positive it's a net worth it thing no it
is and i think at the same time
i think people do need to say whatever
they want to say on either side of it if
what people are saying is hurtful or
malicious then they'll probably pay a
price for it and if what they're saying
has some intelligence behind it then
ultimately most majority of people will
hear that i think that's a part of it
too
you know like with people's we're
getting in trouble for their tweets and
stuff from the past well a lot of their
tweets are really insensitive and
not smart
just make sure whatever your opinion
you're saying is coming from a a
well-rounded thoughtful place because if
it's not yeah you're gonna get attacked
for it uh this has been so
it's been great uh i've really enjoyed
this i feel like the last time i saw you
we went to like a pavement concert
together
i feel like that was it like we went to
the hollywood bowl
you came with mayor elizabeth and i to
see that 90s band pavement oh my god
that's right yeah i don't think you knew
the now
you're a real men steven go oh yeah oh
i'm johnny uh down for anything
that's actually embarrassing you want to
go see sure
yeah
yeah like kramer
yeah one of the reasons i love doing
this is like just very selfishly i get
to
because we wouldn't have made a plan to
see each other and connect that's true
you know when people start making stuff
together again let's let's let's do
another movie i would love it
let's see if i can put the nail on the
coffin of that career for you
it's close we're close
uh i can shut that down
uh okay buddy well i can't wait and i
can't wait to see it be fun all right
all right all right see ya how do we i
never also know how to end
you just leave it press leave meeting
all right
bye buddy
[Music]
you know there's a little bit i've
always and i think this is one of the
reasons i like him and i just realized
that the kind of three who do you think
he sounds like one two three
oh bobcat yeah he does a little bobcat
oh my god [ __ ] he's a mix of bobcat
goldthwait and michael j fox yeah oh
both of whom i really loved growing up i
mean more michael j fox obviously but
he's got
he's always to me had a michael j fox
energy hey yeah i mean there's like doc
doc are you telling me i mean there's a
thing i'm telling you combine those two
voices yeah bobcat how does bobcat go
the weight that's right
it's hard to do him i'd have to i
haven't heard him i don't think i think
that's really good no thanks but bobcat
goldwater doesn't sound like that now
you know have you heard no
yeah i have maybe that's why i can't too
because he hasn't that i didn't realize
what a put on that voice was what an
affect he was doing he was doing a
character right yeah
everything yeah that must have been
exhausting it's sort of like um oh who
is gilbert gottfried a bit like that yes
gilbert he doesn't normally sound like
that no but his whole stick is that
character like this and then you meet
him and he's just a little bit like that
i mean there's like a little hint of it
but he's really doing a thought yeah
he's really doing a shtick
who else carrot top uh seemed like much
more normal it's interesting to meet
these guys that have like forged uh real
personas forged
really yeah
and then you meet him and it's like whoa
jay leno reminds me a little bit about
it like that i just said what he's doing
and you meet him backstage and he's like
oh say you're from connecticut huh yeah
it's weird yeah it must be exhausting i
know a persona is that
i've never thought about it or you just
get so used to it that you don't even
think about it anymore or or paul p
herman
i mean
hey having to do that all the time that
voice and then you meet paul rubens and
he's like hi yeah he's just like
oh he has a kind of a normal voice well
i think maybe
that's why he got in trouble because he
was so used to putting on this
uh caricature that it it drove him horny
that's an interesting theory um yeah but
charlie that's his voice i mean char and
i love it i just like you know it's
funny that he was like i don't think i i
don't think i have a weird voice what do
you know what he said and no one ever
told him that like in my head i sound
like james earl jones
he's so
i love him so much it was so great
catching up with him and uh
sometimes i wonder if it's like i hope
it's entertaining to listen to but i
think that was entertaining yeah he's
such a
he's such a smart funny person um you're
very similar you have i think
you had similar
upbringings our parents sound pretty
similar kind of
somewhat academic academic
creative um yeah middle class new
england uh-huh there's uh there's some
commonalities there yeah when i met him
which is now a long time ago i always
felt very
easy he's very easy for me to be around
him and
um i i was so grateful that they cast
him in that movie and going the distance
because i i knew what a big deal that
was just surrounding yourselves because
with funny people good people yeah so
we've got sedakiss and charlie and uh
god it's kristen shaw and other really
great
uh jim gaffigan such a good cast that's
a i think a really underrated movie i
think romantic comedies in general
are
tough but um i think he had a he had a
smart perspective on it you know he
thought
that it was it was just bad timing among
other things you know the fact that it
was like a year or two away from the
superhero boom yeah where every movie
that did at all well at the box office
was a superhero movie so it's kind of
near the end of an era where romantic
comedies performed well at the box
office but it was still in that era so
the fact that it didn't do well the box
office it reflected it was like a really
bad thing but now i think he's right if
a movie like that a romantic comedy
comes out of netflix or something
and it doesn't do well it's like who
gives a [ __ ] those movies come and go
and and also there's so many
movies romantic comedies specifically on
netflix that i've seen that are so bad
that you just kind of forget about the
next day but that movie was really good
i thought well but it just wasn't like
the stakes were particularly innovative
you know as yeah it wasn't 500 days of
summer or right it wasn't we had the
same director of photography they were
going for that because that had been a
hit the summer before and i remember
thinking yeah like you said how
innovative that that was and i mean the
direction the acting's great and all
that but but it's really innovatively
directed that movie uh ironically that
director went on to do a spider-man
movie yeah um mark webb mark webb yeah i
think that movie
just as it was was really really good it
would i but i think it was bad timing
and it was also the fact that you and
drew were together and yeah it was i i
think people were kind of sick of it and
he was right when he talked about seeing
tabloids and he said something like
people see it at the checkout line they
see these pictures and it it almost like
the thought of paying money to go right
see those two people that i see for free
that i'm annoyed by
in the checkout line that never occurred
to me i remember again adam shankman our
producer he said to me because i had
been cast in the movie
and um
adam came to me and he said hey how
would you feel about drew doing it
because he he knew that we had you know
we had been we had a personal
relationship and um and i thought
she's a wonderful actress she's somebody
that i'm very comfortable with obviously
and like we get along great why not i
mean i don't know it never occurred to
me that there could be any sort of bad
side to working with somebody that good
but um i think like you said just
because we had baggage yeah and nothing
against her or yeah you two together i
mean you obviously have a lot of
chemistry but
but there's something about
that
about the perception of also that she is
this huge it still is this huge movie
star like america's sweetheart
type figure yeah and
you're starring in a romantic comedy
with her it's not gonna seem like you
had the part your part first it's gonna
seem like oh she got her boyfriend right
hooked up with this part so it's gonna
and then once that movie doesn't do that
well at the box office then it's really
on you you know yeah but whatever it was
you know we talked about it was just
such a joy to do it and
i just loved working with charlie and he
was he was so those scenes were so
[ __ ] fun to do because
he's one of the best improvers i've ever
worked with and
he's very real he's real he's grounded
um that's the interesting thing about
his voice is that he has a
you know a very unique character voice
but everything he does and he and i know
on it's always sunny in philadelphia he
does outrageous things yeah but it's
interesting you're right it's an
interesting combination of a really
character-y voice but he doesn't push
the uh push the envelope character-wise
he's very real he's very grounded he's a
grounded guy who happens to have a funny
voice yeah it's such a good combination
that shows i didn't know that that when
it first uh came on it got terrible
reviews and it was
this is how you know a show is
successful that when it's been on so
long that the original reviewers who
wrote shitty reviews about it are like
we were 15 years later like actually you
know yeah in hindsight
it's actually we were wrong it was
really good i wonder if uh what there's
there's an infamous review of back to
the future i think it's the la times i
wonder if they ever walk that back
there's like one really bad scathing
review and it's like this movie will
never last and never stand the test of
time it's so funny yeah that must feel
so great
to be him and to then to see a reviewer
change their mind i know that's like the
ultimate oh my god vindication it's
crazy that big lebowski got bad reviews
that's what he compared it to how could
you give that movie bad review well
again i mean
i remember seeing it for the first time
do you remember seeing big lebowski it
was the movie right after fargo i mean
we talk about this i like it more than
fargo i do too but it's such an original
that like
it is you almost have to and especially
coming off of fargo they're such
different movies right that's true i
just i remember i can only speak first
you know from my own taste i remember
seeing and being like ah and now it's
one of my favorite movies also tonally
it has that crazy shift
once he gets knocked out and it gets all
trippy
and bob dylan yeah from then on it
becomes so trippy and like stonery yeah
at a certain point it's a huge shift and
i think that's true i like it i love it
but but you have to like if going into
that movie if you're not used to seeing
yeah like that if you're not ready for
it i thought this was a comedy funny
when they when you're you're like how
did they how did you guys get danny
devito and he's like oh well he was like
a fan of the show and
he was looking to do something and
uh his daughter like recommended him and
he's like and they paid him a lot of
money
yeah he paid him money i gave him up
turns out he likes cash hey
yeah he's told that story about drew
punching
the girl in the movie i forgot about
that
and so funny i could totally picture
that i feel like i've seen her do that
in a million oh yeah when she gets that
like wiley looks
like
i will take anyone down it's funny
because people know her
so clearly as uh yeah you know like a
certain yeah like america's sweeter yeah
but i think people also know her as like
a tough you know charlie's angels that
kind of yeah yeah all right but i don't
think people
really know i play board games with her
no i don't think people really know
like the real
like down and dirty competitive version
wow that's some of my favorite
stuff yeah about her and it's like her
when we went lobster
oh with her idea and she like speared
like 10 times more lobsters than anybody
oh she was like a mermaid with a triton
she was like uh trident trident yeah she
gets that like wily look i remember now
i mean this is what worries me about my
bad memory like i that's such a fun
memory and i it was gone
and that's also what i love about
catching up with old friends it's like
you get to be reminded you're just like
you funny you said that to him do you
not remember saying that to me no oh
jesus oh god it's all right oh boy hey
let's read a letter okay great here's a
letter from margaret subject
well [ __ ] how y'all doing
that's good
hey leslie jordan hi justin and
christian another connecticut native
here i've been listening since the
beginning thanks to my other favorite
podcast armchair expert god another yet
another thanks to dex
pre-coveted i would listen to podcasts
on my commute to work and on long walks
with my dog i've been listening from
home since mid-march and two weeks into
quarantine my dog had major knee surgery
oh this i didn't know dogs could have
knee surgery i was gonna say i didn't
know dogs could have major knee
surgeries yeah our dad had major knee
surgery last year
he's not a dog um
wow that's interesting glad you
clarified that for everybody yeah it
must have been a big dog i would imagine
have needs to
maybe little dogs could have knee
surgery maybe without my commute or
daily walks i've fallen quite behind i
just listened to the chelsea handler
episode and literally laughed out loud
when you were talking about frogs and
christians said quote i love seeing them
hop i don't i don't remember you saying
that i oh you did maybe yeah yeah i like
i think you were like i like seeing them
yeah i thought it was more yeah i i
don't mind isn't that funny this is how
necessary context is i'd be surprised if
i said i love seeing them hop
you sound like oh i love seeing them hot
like every morning i look forward i
remember you saying that in the the
context was i mean i liked that like
because i was like you don't like frogs
do you something like that and i was
seeing them hop yeah or something like
that
it definitely wasn't like i love seeing
them hop okay anyway something about the
visual of the typically stoic christian
getting joy out of a frog hopping just
cracked me up oh that is funny
i guess i am stoic you are that's a
compliment i think i i wish i were more
stoic you also mentioned that listening
to chelsea's show makes you feel like
you know her i have to say i feel the
same way with you guys i especially
loved listening to your siblings oh i
she said i have to say i feel the same
way with you guys you didn't put the
emphasis on no wrong uh wrong word that
was my fault i especially loved
listening to your sibling banter pre
post show and the little tidbits at the
end of as it reminds me
days when
my siblings and i would sit all around
cracking each other up over the silliest
things
that's cool thank you for sharing so
much of yourselves with us all now more
than ever it's nice to feel connected to
other people keep it up why wr
would you rather oh
god
oh boy
all right
boy
here we go would you rather
have to sing every word you speak for
the rest of your life oh half have to
say yeah i have to sing every word have
to sing every word you speak for the
rest of your life oh my god the second
one
is gonna have to be really terrible
it's like
yeah
or have a completely monotone voice that
never changes in volume that is really
good a completely monotone voice or have
a completely monotone voice that never
changes in volume um what's the volume
can you pick the volume
or do you have to set it at some point i
imagine
could it be any volume you want but you
have to set it
uh you'd want one right in the mid
probably like right about here you would
want it to be loud if you only get one
volume yeah you'd want it to be like
this what yeah
so anytime you want to get somebody's
attention think about think about it
being too loud in life
is more problematic than being too quiet
that's true so if you had to pick one
one volume you would have to just get
used to being close you would have to
get christian's just cheering with his
hands oh yeah that's true i should
explain that you're like
like like a traffic like a traffic cop
it would be annoying for sure to have to
call people over and to talk but they
get used to your friends exactly and
strangers you're right if you talk like
this all the time
in a public place will ferrell's
character what's that character that's
that's one of my favorite feral
characters
all right voice modulation disorders a
real problem tina fey you know i think i
would definitely pick the monotone one
because
i already know people in life who are
like 95 percent of the way to monotone
and i don't know anyone who sings
everything so uh i know people who are
sing songs yeah that's different than
singing everything
every word you speak for the rest of
your life i mean you don't have to sing
it that um
i'm assuming that you don't have to put
much effort into it either way either
option you pick like if if you sing
everything you wouldn't have to
think
i could just say it like that and it
wouldn't have to be something that you'd
have to think i mean also think about
like crash test dummies
i mean you could do everything like once
there was a guy i mean they're barely
singing you could think about rat lil
uzi vert
he sings you could argue
uh
yeah
but i mean you could do everything like
this but so i'm saying if you take the
effort just jazz it up a little bit if
you take the effort equation away yeah
you know if it's not because my instinct
was oh singing is much more difficult
you have to think about it all the time
but i'm assuming in this hypothetical it
just comes naturally you don't have to
create lovely realities right
but still
then when you think about other people
having to experience you
and uh and deal with you in life
it's much much less annoying
to deal with a monotone person
yes then a person who sings everything i
don't think come on you're
giving that enough mother monotone how
obnoxious that might get after a while
if you were working at a deli okay and
you were taking orders someone came in
line you came in line and like bread
would you like that on and you were like
i'll have a bologna sandwich
with mustard and a pickle
do you know how
i mean it'd be funny i'll have a baloney
sandwich with mustard and a pickle
it's so much weirder
it's weird so much more embarrassing how
about this it'll give people more joy
then this voice will
this would just get like oh my god what
a turn off that would be especially for
like a single person like me to go on a
date and everything's like so tell me a
little bit about yourself okay let's see
you on the date singing so where do you
work
by the way have you ever been to this
restaurant she's like uh oh [ __ ] my
roommate's calling me uh no way either
way she'd put user out here she'd call
her like the sing-songy thing is who are
you texting on youtube here's the
difference it's such a simple difference
one you would seem insane yeah and the
other you would seem dull
which would you rather seem that's what
it comes down to uh dollar instead i'd
rather seem insane
i said that like jerry
yeah you know i'd
rather seem insane that's uh i feel like
i just got a window into your
personality well
i would rather seem dull you would
rather see him saying yeah that's a good
question by the way on the podcast yeah
it's actually a really
uh interesting difference between us
yeah this is a great would you rather
look with inspiration dull or insane
yeah i'd rather because i be because
i've also known people you know who's a
little like uh sing-song is jack mcbride
oh my god jack mcbrayer is like eight
percent sing-songy this is a hundred
percent yeah i just keep thinking of
christmas prayer would be great on the
podcast oh yeah you know i
i talked to him the other day uh
yeah of course jl anytime
yeah no that was too leslie jordan
absolutely absolutely he's just oh he's
the best okay uh speaking of great
voices um thank you so much to our
just uh
yeah i love him charlie day did the best
he's excellent
yeah so thanks charlie thanks for doing
that and for everyone who listened and
for marvel thank you margaret for that
uh great letter really sweet letter and
hey to all margaret i hope you're like i
hope your dog is doing better oh yeah
and uh and that was a great would you
rather thank you for yeah for that and
if you guys would like to write in our
email address is justin please life is
short at wondery.com
that's a little more bobcat gold weight
yeah
yeah yeah thanks to everyone who's been
listening and we will talk to you next
week
have a great week life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me yeah it's
co-hosted and produced by you you never
said your name oh oh
oh
justin long it's produced and co-hosted
by christian long and megan monco senior
producer is michelle
audio engineer is sergio enriquez
executive producers are
marcia louis and arnon lopez for who
wondering see you next week
[Music]
you know i would like to have one of
these with charlie day he seems like a
good guy to have bud light seltzer with
doesn't he he does now
if this sounds different to you like
wait a minute why do they keep
mentioning bud light seltzer you should
know a we love it and that's been
established but b and they're paying for
the show you don't have to pay for the
show
you can listen to the show and enjoy it
enjoy great guests like show a day
here's something else you can enjoy
responsibly bud light seltzer yeah
before you listen to your next podcast
do me a favor go to the store and get
some bud light seltzer try it life is
short at wondering.com
let us know how you liked it just crack
one open because at the very least
you'll be supporting the show remember
enjoy it responsibly anheuser-busch st
louis missouri
you